disbelievers, those who have
associated partners unto Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala and why it
is they have turned away from
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's
guidance. Why have they turned
away from it? Why have they
rebelled against the messenger
of Allah? Well, one of the
reasons for this, is that they
have been too comfortable for
too long.
says that which translates to
Rather, it is that we have
given them and their
forefathers comfort for
extended period of time. until
their lives became very long
and comfortable and plentiful
This is one of the leading
causes for a person to turn
away from the truth. Too much
comfort too long. When comfort
is no longer used by the human
being, as a tool to excel, and
it is rather made and used as
an ends in itself, then it
becomes destructive. What does
this mean? When a person is
striving to advance, to become
better, to excel, They must use
comfort as a kind of carrot on
a stick that they dangle ahead
of themselves. They're striving
with the idea of I shall be
rewarded with comfort. This is
how a person motivates himself.
But when a person has too much
of the carrot. When a person no
longer uses comfort as an
incentive and rather comfort in
and of itself becomes the ends
in themselves. And now become
destructive because anytime a
person finds comfort, they will
leave off discipline, they will
leave off hard work, and they
will tend towards the comfort.
This is destructive. Discipline
is based on a number of things
and one of these is delaying
gratification as psychologist
mentioned in their books. It's
called Delaying Gratification.
What does that mean? That
reward of comfort, of pleasure,
the longer you are able to
delay it, the more you will
excel behind it. You use it as
a tool to propel you But when
comfort in and of itself
becomes your goal. Now
everything starts to fall
apart. Because whenever you are
presented comfort you will
leave off hard work. for that.
For that easy comfort. To cash
it in because after all that's
your goal. Nothing else. And
so, we find this in our modern
culture
that we have this false notion
that we are here to pursue
happiness. Why are we here? Oh,
to be happy, to pursue
happiness. It's even in the
constitution. right? The
pursuit of happiness. This is
not a very good pursuit As a
not a very good, meaningful
pursuit because if we all only
pursue that which made us
happy, we would be pretty
terrible people. Rather, we are
to pursue that which is
meaningful And that which is
meaningful may make us happy
along the way. And it may make
us sad along the way. But we
pursue that which is
meaningful. Not necessarily
that which is makes us happy.
Happiness.
And so, when a person tends
towards comfort and pleasure
too much, this will disrupt a
person's discipline. Person
must use comfort and pleasure
sparingly. Only as a propelling
force, as an incentive to
continue to advance, to
continue to do and pursue that
which is meaningful. This is
the purpose of comfort on this
Earth. Otherwise, comfort does
not usually produce any very
very good results for human
beings. Actually, it could be
said that comfort is a great
enemy to human advancement.
That the more people become
comfortable, the more they are
lulled into. and are lulled
into self-centeredness and lazi
and a lack of discipline and a
lack of meaning because a
person becomes person reaches
this ends of pleasure and they
stop advancing. They stop
growing. They stop developing.
And this is very dangerous for
a person. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala continues on. in the
next verse. Say to them. It is
merely by revelation that I
warn you all. Not from myself.
Not from my own self, for my
own words. It is by revelation
that I instruct you and warn
you. Yet, those who are deaf,
cannot hear the call even when
they are warned. This deafness
that Allah is speaking about
here is a spiritual deafness.
Meaning that they are deaf and
immune to anything that is of
consequence in real in in
reality for them. It is if they
can't hear it all. They might
as well be completely deaf
because they cannot hear that
which is most important and
pertinent from that which they
are warned and that which they
are told by Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala and his messenger. He
goes on to state subhanahu wa
ta'ala that which translates to
and indeed if a single blast or
blow of the punishment of your
Lord were to touch them they
would immediately wail. Indeed,
woe to us, we were surely
astray. We're surely wrong.
Meaning, that this pain, as
soon as it hits their system,
they will immediately they will
immediately
leave off all of these
all of these arguments that
they come up with, all of these
reasons why they claim that
they don't believe and the
truth will come out, that they
honestly do believe. All of
that will be pushed aside and
it will be just true
objectivity. They will
immediately proclaim that they
were wrong. Why is that? Pain
as a very interesting way of
making the human being
objective. There is, there are
few things in this world that
will make a person see things
for what they really are like
pain. and few things in this
world that will make a person
more humble and pain As soon as
that pain hits the system a lot
of that ego and a lot of that
arguing and a lot of that
bickering and bickering and all
of this games that people like
to play Evaporates. and a
person at that moment will do
anything to make the pain stop.
And if the pain is to stop by
telling the truth even if it is
humiliating, the person will do
so. Because there is nothing
pain. Notice here
Allah mentions that pleasure On
one hand, is what's causing
them to argue and bicker and
lie And notice here how pain
will cause
them to be truthful
and honest even at their own
expense, the expense of their
own egos. and this is how a
person naturally is. Yet, a
person who has disciplined
himself pleasure will not bring
out the worst in them and pain
will not necessarily bring out
the best in them. A person who
has disciplined himself to tell
the truth no matter what.
Person who has disciplined
himself to follow the truth no
matter where it leads. This
person, person of Tuckwa,
person of worship of Allah
Subhanahu wa ta'ala. Pain will
only increase their embracing
of the truth and pleasure will
not.
their pursuit of the truth.
[Arabic recitation]